in a world where women are shortchanged
and overlooked one industry dares to
take gender inequality to a whole new
level Hollywood that's right it's the
start of the summer blockbuster season
and even though half of moviegoers are
women the film biz is one of the most
unequal when it comes to gender and
that's why women directors and the ACLU
have filed a complaint petitioning the
government to investigate Hollywood's
gender bias how is it come to this let's
start with the films themselves in all
of last year's films women made up a
mere 13% of lead roles and for speaking
roles it was only 30 percent in
comparison that's only 5 percent more
speaking roles than in the 1940s and 50s
Julia cheerio at that rate women in film
won't be on par with men until the year
22 95 right around the time rising
sea-levels wipe out Hollywood and when
we do see women in film
they're often hyper sexualized over the
last few years 28 percent of actresses
were shown partially naked that's
compared to only 9.5 percent of men so
unfair but what about the female
powerhouses Angelina Jolie and Sandra
Bullock are running things right
you'd think what did you know in 2014
the top 10 actresses made half as much
of the top 10 actors Bullock the top
paid actress raked in 51 million but the
top paid actor of that year Robert
Downey jr. made 75 million and last
year's leaked Sony emails further
confirmed Hollywood's pay gap it was
revealed that Amy Adams made far less
than Bradley Cooper on the profits of
American hustle even though she played a
lead role and had more screen time but
behind the camera the gender imbalance
is especially stark there are 5 times
more men than women working on top
grossing films that's the same ratio of
men to women in active duty and that
number hasn't changed since the 90s also
only 1.9 percent of blockbusters in the
last two years were directed by women I
spoke with Maria
an indie filmmaker with 20 years of
experience in Hollywood it's really
extraordinary and hypocritical I think
that in Liberal Democratic Hollywood
where we have the worst numbers of
gender discrimination of any industry in
the United States it really is that bad
she was fed up with sexism in the
Directors Guild of America an
eighty-year-old group of mostly men
which guy says sets the tone of the
industry so she called him the ACLU to
intervene Hollywood is an industry and
Hollywood is not exempt from our civil
rights laws I really felt that if the
ACLU didn't come through for me and for
us women directors that I wasn't going
to be able to do anything dlu filed an
official complaint with the Equal
Employment Opportunity Commission
Tinseltown is a boys club guy says and
nobody wants to take a risk by hiring a
female director what do you say to
someone who says well what does it
matter that there are women in the
industry when you have a woman director
then you're going to get a more accurate
picture of gender and more authentic
portrayal of women our television shows
and our feature films are the cultural
voice of our civilization and when you
have the cultural voice of our
civilization reflecting just one gender
then you're not getting an accurate
portrayal of what our world looks like
the evidence is clear so when will it
finally be a rap for sexism in film